I'll start by creating a jQuery
collection of all the elements of class
article item then I'll call find on the
article items and pass it ul to find all
instances of unordered lists in the
collection now I have to be careful I'm
actually telling jQuery to select all
you ELLs from any of the article items
in this case I only have one right here
but if I had more than one I'd need to
use a more specific selector or filtered
somehow otherwise I delete other ul
elements at this point I'll simply
remove the ul and presto it is gone
alternatively according to the
documentation you can also pass a
selector into dot remove to only remove
specific elements from the Dom for
instance if you only wanted to remove
elements with class bold you could pass
in the selector bold and you'd only see
James disappear can hit test scroll down
and James is gone